How often should I get blood work? Well, it really depends on the person. So it depends on
each person
what their previous blood work was
and each person what they are doing that could alter their blood work. So all right, let's use the example number one
What their previous blood work was if your previous blood work was completely normal
then
You can you know, there's more of a time that you could wait to get another test
If your previous blood work was abnormal that I will tell you ask me I will tell you when we should get more blood work
Because we want to look at those abnormalities and see what we need to do if we can do anything to alter those objective findings
Number three is the person who's doing something that could
Hinder their blood work or cause some abnormal findings and the best example would be you're taking fenbedes on
So if you're taking fenbedes all we would need to get your blood work in least every 30 days
Because we need to make sure that you're not getting liver issues from the fenbedes on
So make sure we do that. So that's my rule and I've stated it under times if you're doing fenbedes all
We need to get your blood work every 30 days and the only exception of that is if we've gone 30 days
Oh, it's hasn't hurt my liver markers at all. We do another 30 days. I still I'm taking fenbedes all
You know, maybe daily and it's it hasn't done anything to my liver markers. Okay, let's wait two months now
So if it's good to affect your liver, it's gonna affect your liver
You know usually relatively quick within the first month you're gonna see you know your alkaline phosphatase
HST and ALT possibly go up
Because it's negatively affected your liver. So if you're doing something that's negatively affected your liver
Or if you have you know increased next example would be a change in symptoms
I've been doing really well
And I haven't had blood work for three months
But oh son, it's just something's wrong with me. I just exhausted all the time
I'm just super fatigued. I don't feel good. Okay, we need to get some blood work and find out what's going on
So if you have a change in the subjective finding that we need to look at objective findings. So
Those would be things up top my head. There's probably others, but those would be things up to top my head
Why you would get blood work?